we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P if you have something to
say to me
you can say it to my voicemail line even
if it's 3am when you get the idea
um here is the Eggman he is not buying
my entire I'm Argentinian thing at least
not in terms of me just being a white
guy take a listen to this
hi Dave
I've won the FIFA thing you know
whatever right um congratulations to you
the Eggman is not big on Sports and he
will admit that to you David you're a
New York white guy okay
I'm gonna have to agree with Donald
Trump over you yeah in the pronunciation
of his soccer draw a soccer freaking
sock draw okay you put your socks in the
drawer and you close it what's the
problem
Shalom brother
sock drawer
yeah listen uh I didn't grow up in New
York so I have not adopted any of these
New York accent elements uh I believe
that my accent is What's called the
southern western New England accent
and sock draw doesn't make any sense to
me it's it's a sock drawer it's a drawer
it's a a number of drawers many drawers
draw Brian doesn't make any sense uh but
in any case
it the story Trump told about the sock
draw was very much untrue okay on the
bonus show today what the hell happened
with the FAA and all flights being
temporarily grounded and how much blame
does Secretary of Transportation Pete
boot Edge bootage Edge how much blame
does uh secretary Pete
deserve Fox News thinks it's a lot and
we'll talk about it the Biden
Administration is going to be selecting
the first 10 drugs for which it will
negotiate prices within the Medicare
program by September
what drugs might those be we will
discuss and what will the impact on
pricing be we will also talk about that
and lastly House Republicans they want
people back to work they want everybody
back in the office House Republicans are
introducing a bill to return all federal
employees to the office I have a number
of friends who are federal employees and
uh they aren't thrilled and I understand
why many of their jobs really don't need
to be done in an office quite frankly we
will talk about it on the bonus show
when producer Pat joins me from sunny
Florida you can get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money please everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah well I don't know about that
but you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code 24
starts now to save big you get 100 of
the benefits but at half the price hard
to beat that I will see you on the bonus
show